so parents are voting out their school
boards pulling their children out of
public schools they're doing it for a
reason they don't want their kids to be
indoctrinated by crazy people rachel
wilson is a homeschooling advocate who
lives in a rural midwest she understands
what's happening and the scale of it she
joins us tonight rachel thanks so much
for coming on
so
how big has homeschooling become in the
face of the collapse of public education
thank you so much for having me on
tucker
this pandemic we are now two years into
it and homeschooling has increased
four-fold from the beginning of the
pandemic to last fall according to a u.s
census survey
in addition to that
yeah it's the biggest that we've ever
seen and in addition to that we're
hearing data scientists tell us that a
full 25 of all jobs in north america
will be remote by the end of this year
so i don't think this trend is going
anywhere and i think a lot more parents
are going to be
finding themselves at home a lot more
often with their children which i think
is a wonderful silver lining to this
situation i don't think that anybody
watching this show
could say they're fully satisfied with
how authority figures have handled this
pandemic we see oligarchs around the
world
trying to
institute a great reset and kind of
remake society in their image
but the good thing is that what man
intends for evil god uses for good
so we have a golden opportunity here
which is that
the biggest demographic of people who
have left the workforce and either
stayed home or started working remotely
are mothers of school-age children so
we're in a special situation to take
advantage of this and use it to our own
benefit
to kind of get away from
sending our kids somewhere seven or
eight hours a day to be indoctrinated by
people who quite frankly are enemies to
a more traditional conservative or
christian way of life and instead of
those people teaching our children our
morals our culture our values we can go
back to having parents and mothers uh
teaching our kids those values
i mean i what you described is beautiful
and they are avowed enemies of your
family and of your children very quickly
i think the main concern for a lot of
people thinking about this is well will
my kids grow up to be weird i mean are
they socialized at all with no with no
classmates
right that people have a lot of concerns
or worries when they think about
homeschooling
public education is actually kind of new
it's only really been the standard for
about a century and prior to that we had
other ways of educating people so the
good news i tell people is that it's
really not that hard you do not have to
be an expert you don't have to be a
teacher
and you don't have to worry about not
being able to socialize your kids either
we have so many
ways that we can do that now especially
with
the internet all the bad that comes with
it there's a lot of good too
so we can
we can get children into church we can
get them into intramural sports and a
lot of public schools also let kids do
sports and band and things like that
through the school as well well they
should you pay for them
rachel thanks for joining us also a
firearms instructor i should i should
point out great to see you thanks so
much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else